our next guest has been on the ground
talking to migrants border agents and
reporting on all of this chaos
investigative reporter savannah
hernandez joins us now savannah um just
bring us the latest what have you been
seeing in hearing
thank you so much for having me on so
what i want to speak about today is the
fact that not one but two whistleblowers
came forward last week and spoke to me
one of those whistleblowers was an
active national guardsman talking to me
about mutilated bodies that the cartel
is leaving on the u.s side of the border
as an intimidation tactic how the cartel
is shooting at national guardsmen and
border patrol members every single day
because they know they can get away with
it under joe biden's administration on
top of that we're of course continually
hearing the stories and the reports and
seeing the video imagery of children
that have been abandoned at the border i
myself have seen this in yuma arizona on
top of you know at the beginning of the
night 25 illegal immigrants making their
way across the border at 12 a.m by 6 a.m
there were 400 people lined up many of
these people children one of them an
abandoned child in the desert so
absolutely shocking what we're seeing
right now again going back to national
guard they had provided me with the
picture the cartel had burned this
individual's face off with acid left the
body on the u.s side of the border for
them to find because again the cartel is
absolutely emboldened under this
administration it's horrifying to see i
went to piedras negras as well to speak
to the migrants as they made their way
to our southern border that's one of the
last cities that they enter before
crossing into eagle pass texas i was
asking them hey where are you headed and
uh do you think that the border is open
they were telling me they were going to
california of course that they were
headed to new york washington dc georgia
tennessee they're going everywhere and
they said joe biden's border is wide
open we think that he's a great man
because he's providing us with so much
opportunity and that's why we're making
the trek uh the new york times also just
put out a piece regarding the cartels
you know they were making about 500
million dollars back in 2018 under joe
biden's administration they're making 13
billion so there's so much going on on
top of that my second whistleblower was
an employee from mvm inc this was the
same company that was caught uh
illegally not illegally because it's
illegal under the biden administration
but cops shipping migrants in the middle
of the night to new york right those
secret night flights so he actually
works as a youth care escort and he
works with kids as young as one month up
to 17 years of age and he basically told
me how they're putting 200 to 300
children on these charter flights and
shipping them to new york california
oregon washington all over the u.s and
so many people keep asking me isn't this
considered child trafficking well yes it
technically would be but under the biden
administration this is essentially legal
nvm inc signed a federal contract with
the biden administration for 136 million
dollars back in 2021 so our taxpayer
dollars going towards funding all of
this i wrote pieces on the
post-millennial for both of these
stories and i'd highly encourage people
to go and read the pieces because again
on top of these children being shipped
throughout the united states
the employee that spoke to me provided
me with an email that was basically
stating that these children were being
handed over to improperly identified
adults meaning that the paper that the
office of refugee resettlement is giving
these employees they're not making sure
that the adult on the paper matches the
adult they're handing this child over to
and it's absolutely insane
you know what's incredible about about i
mean and i'm sure this is just a kind of
small snapshot of everything you've been
uncovering i mean it's even worse than
than we think i mean you know we've all
been watching bill milligan's fantastic
reporting i mean you've gone behind the
scenes you've talked to the agent you've
got these whistleblowers it's even worse
than we thought and we know it's
absolutely catastrophic what is
unbelievable just final thoughts about i
mean what do you make of the democrat
insistence still they insist the border
is not open the border is secure majors
were saying that just the other day the
other week and that their policy is
humane
yeah the biden administration is an
absolute joke and they're liars i've
gone down there myself and any single
american can go do this and they can
watch illegals flood our border every
single day okay they're coming across
here because they know that america is
open for business and this
administration can continue to lie to
the american people but we can see
what's going on we can see the
demographic of our own country changing
in lifetime and we can see the crime
rate surging as the cartel is allowed to
run rampant well that's exactly right
and we see and you mentioned california
i mean just the scale of the impact just
of one part of this the fentanyl on on
kids and families in california never
mind the rest of the country is just
absolutely uh shocking and it just gets
worse and worse um thank you savannah
for you for being with us tonight but
also for your reporting you know i know
you'll keep it up and hopefully we'll
see you again um because this isn't
going to change as long as this
administration
doesn't change great to see you thank
you hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else